yeah my neighbors are playing music so
[ __ ] loud right now don't they know I
have to react to a video hey guys I'm
Ryan right so today we're gonna check
out the official trailer number one for
the hateful eight
this is Tarantino's new film there was
all that our deal about hey as script
got leaked I'm not gonna make it I'm
gonna make it anyway and now we're here
the thing about Tarantino trailers that
kind of annoys me is not the trailers
themselves it's the way a lot of people
respond to the trailers because if you
notice Tarantino movies are pretty hard
to market and get the right trailer down
I've never seen a Tarantino trailer been
like that's gonna be the best one he's
ever done but Kill Bill and Django
Unchained are actually my favorite
Tarantino films they inglorious basterds
one I remember not being too psyched
about it and I ended up loving that film
let's keep that in mind when we watch
this that trailers for his movies don't
ever really represent a true form of his
films I want to watch this the path the
project was so passionate to him that he
was like even though the script about
leaked I'm gonna make it anyway that
sounds awesome let's do this
[Music]
beautiful asking a man brave a blizzard
kill in cold blood
I'm sure I don't know you'd be surprised
what a man start see pictures ain't got
room for one more to be handin out rides
real Trustin feller huh not so much in
no way I'm spending a couple of nights
under a roof with somebody I don't know
who they are
so who are you nice
it's a pretty sweet trailer actually
ok everybody hear this I'm taking this
woman to head for Awards $10,000 that
money's mine boys that's interesting
[Music]
that's my problem
boy I don't know
one of themselves will kill everybody in
here now we're talking
[Music]
let's lower down this Lord Wade
[Music]
let me get to tell me Daisy
[Music]
[Music]
no one said this job supposed to be
somebody says we'll be there alright
neither
[Music]
spend the holidays with someone you hate
do that okay I know I talked the whole
thing about like a trailer trip to that
trailer was [ __ ] sweet what I'm
loving about what they're at least
promoting here is energy of the
characters the flavor of their
personality like everyone seems pretty
loud in this filming you know it seems a
little bit more heightened and
personality than I'm used to from
Tarantino films like there's usually a
character too it seems like everyone in
this film is pretty loud for the most
part maybe Michael Madsen will be the
calm one and they're really showing Kurt
Russell's pretty much as the lead him
and Samuel Jackson seminole Jackson
seems more like a supporting narrator to
the story but then there's like Kurt
Russell who seems like the lead Kurt
Russell I [ __ ] love this guy I grew
up watching Kurt Russell films [ __ ]
all the John Carpenter collaborations he
did I [ __ ] loved him in backdraft
Kurt Russell was just the coolest dude
man and I loved his work he did with
Tarantino and death Proof so you know
these two can work together well and
what I really love too is they're really
showing that Samuel Jackson is gonna be
a badass
Samuel Jackson lately has been getting
put in a lot of roles you know excluding
Nick Fury that are more fun and over the
top even in the last few Tarantino
appearances he's made and Kill Bill Vol
- he was that dude playing the piano and
he was a cool dude but you know he
didn't do anything really cool and
inglourious basterds he just had some
narration in there and Django Unchained
he wasn't a badass in Django Unchained
now it's like now he's wielding guns
again he's got the cool talking dialogue
and Tarantino has said that Samuel
Jackson carries his lines better than
any other actor out there and I totally
agree with that man like the [ __ ]
flavor to the dialogue
I think Samuel Jackson brings that's the
life in a Tarantino script and Walter
Goggins or dojin's whatever the sheriff
this guy's made appearances in Tarantino
films I've seen a lot of other films
before and I'm glad he's getting a role
that's one of the leads of this film
because he's a
really good actor he tends to just be
put in supporting roles or co-star roles
I'm really glad that he's being up front
for such a you know anticipated film a
hardcore fanbase of Tarantino dudes
wonder if that sentence I said made
sense you know I'm trying to get it it
looks like this stones gonna be funny it
looks like Tarantino's version of like a
psychological western thriller you know
because there's always this humor
infused even and I like that the
trailers really showing that but there's
gonna be a big sense of humor here yeah
I'm down for this movie I'm gonna be
there opening day keep a lookout for my
review anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe today and
become a reject II no no it doesn't work
that doesn't work
Jordan Spicer hi Ryan and fellow rejects
my name is Jordan Spicer I live up in
nunavut canada where not much happens i
just want to say that i've been a fan
from the start you guys have helped me
through a lot of tough times including
my depression when I wondered if life
was worth living yeah I hope one day
when I'm older since I'm only 14 no no
no life is totally worth living my 14
year old friend to come down to
California and hang out with you guys
and even become a reject myself thank
you guys for everything you guys are
like a family
yeah dude Jordan tell you what buddy if
you're ever are down in California I
know you struggle with depression my
friend and I know what it's like to
struggle with depression and since
you're only 14 I'm not gonna give you
some stupid advice like jerking off to
porn even though you probably do that
already fun to be honest with you and I
would say that you know you can do a lot
of things to make you feel better but
the best thing to do is go to the root
cause of your feelings and let stuff go
and really examine yourself it's more
than just a one-time thing this is a
process an ongoing process of constant
examination of yourself you develop
awareness you develop insight into
yourself you develop insight into other
people even better your connection with
people becomes better you learn to be
more honest and you live a better life I
totally recommend therapy you know like
if you've never been to therapy and you
criticize therapy you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
so I'm not saying you have to go to
therapy but I think it would really
benefit you and find the right therapist
because I have to go to like three
different therapists before I found the
one that I'm with for the past couple
years so sometimes it takes going
through a couple therapists to find the
one you really click with and once you
find that stay in there and be honest
and they're raw honest that's the best
advice every time spicer your last name
wait so you're 18 I got some Spicer
jokes I can make mm-hmm like burning
sensations
when you go to the bathroom
I have to see the doctor